welcome back to Las Vegas now Eric  Palacios from Eric Palacios and  Associates shares how to know when you  have the right-of-way while driving in  today's legal minute  hi I'm Eric Palacios welcome to the  legal minute today's question is how do  I know if I have the right of way while  driving  if you're driving on a straight road  with no traffic lights or signs you have  the right of way Vehicles turning into  the road you're on have to yield to you  if you reach an intersection with no  traffic signs or non-operating traffic  lights the first vehicle to reach the  intersection has the right-of-way if two  or more Vehicles reach the intersection  at the same time then the one on the  right has the right of way this has been  the legal minute if you have any legal  questions you can call us at  702-444-7777  an Associates a call at that phone  number or visit their website at  ericolacioslaw.com  [Music]